hallo leute ich es wieder europa bekommt
eine neue ausfahrt video heute mit
sowohl in only soraya meine nächte der
beste und tollste mensch auf der welt
ich habe jetzt jemand von jen sie hier
also ich kann jetzt meine melanie fragen
stellen sie ist das deutsche fernsehen
mit der tagesschau anschließend die
wette
was bedeutet dies also warum macht man
chiche ich mache
was ich
dazu sagen soll was ich benutzt man
nicht auf was ist nur so ironisch
benutzt man das ja okay natürlich
klar dass
prinz gut heute packen wir den pamela
ins kalender aus wir sind wie eine große
familie reifen ich liebe deine markets
camille abily
das gilt endlich hier raus
[Musik]
u
riesig ist es dem dazu schießen
[Gelächter]
o&o wieso das denn stehe ich hab's nicht
mal aufs bild also wir haben ja all den
pamela reiss adventskalender ich hab ihn
am tag bestellt als der ausgaben im
urlaub und da es in der sonne und hab so
schnell mal gedrückt und dann wenn man
ganz schnell aus aber jetzt gibt's sehen
wir also der kostet 54 99 ist schon was
ich meine ja sehr groß da sind ja viele
sachen bestimmt drin ja von ihrer
eigenen marke und neun verschiedenen
abschwung
okay wir schnappen nicht lange rum wir
werden dieses mal wieder die preise nach
rechnen um zu gucken ob es sich
natürlich lohnt für 55 euro und wir
fangen an mit türchen nummer eins es ist
was von nativen ich habe noch nie was
von ihrem produkt tituliert es wäre die
pflicht hier hast du schon mal hier ist
es
also ich würde es soll organic
schokolade sein aber ich glaube die sind
so gut wenn man so kekse oder sowas
backt oder hat keinen keks und dann noch
einmal die kerzen
ist pressig free ja sie sagt sie will
ich viel plastik benutzen das er benutzt
irgendwas anderes das ist biologisch
abbaubar
schmeckt gut aber man springt auf jeden
fall dass dunkle schokolade ist ich habe
jetzt nur so ein und wie schmeckt das
gras und es ist halt kokos blüten zucker
es hat trotzdem 600 kalorien pro monat
also auch wir müssen den preis kurzfilm
nat clusters pina schoko also das zeug
hat auch zu tag wir gucken nach dem
geschmack ist doch eh das nicht so sehen
sie aus
also man schmeckt hier auf jeden fall
ist es nicht so wie sie so ich mag soll
vielseitig das jetzt hier nicht so krass
ist lecker aber es ist okay 100 gramm
kosten 5 euro 54 und hier ist rund 25
grad das sind 1 euro und 38 cent hier
nochmal
ein trainerproblem m3 ist wirst du schon
drin
doha ein stück feste seite ja shampoo
das shampoo kostet sechs euro 95 schon
teuer für shampoo ich hole meine
forschung keine ahnung 2 und türchen
nummer vier
und gemüse bestimmt
es ist ein match ist roger reichel
darauf freue ich mich weil die dann
richtig gut sein aber das ist nicht
ihrer eigenmarke das head-up-display aus
dieser regel kostet 249 2 auch immer so
ein kleines ding ist schon krass namen
brille in ruhe kostenlosen ich liebe
proteinriegel
marketing vor dem geschmack
ich finde ich gut klappt es gut türchen
nummer
das ist für diese unterwäsche marke 20
prozent rabatt und in gerader slip
also die nummer 50 euro es ist nikolaus
türchen nummer sechs meine lieblings tag
seine 61
96 99
sex ist organic coconuts sugar
also für 100 gramm koks bühne sogar muss
man zahlen 1 350 schon mal kokos blüht
sogar probiert nein müssen
morgen die fränkische küche und am
basteln
sport macht mit
wir
cool aber warum sport wenn man dann
damit seinen sport kümmern branchen kann
oder wie ja das sei für den sport stoff
für eine wäsche also dieses sport
waschmittel kostet jetzt
eine wäsche 199
ja das schon cray selber drauf warum so
toll es
ist wieder ein
[Musik]
sehr gut ich bin sehr lecker und dann
halt nicht vergessen das hat auch 22
gramm zucker die süße kommt von den
datteln das ist nämlich die hauptzutat
also es sind erst mal gepresste dafür
mit ganz viel anderes zeug und er kostet
zwei euro 49
die kennen wir doch alle aus dem
supermarkt kennen
das geist an denen ist das sind so
schiffe also das kind
und das bestehen nur aus hier
also sie schmecken auf jeden fall gut 1
eur 24 türchen nummer 10 ach so es sind
geschredderte kokosnüsse auf deutschland
man auf kurs raspeln
credit über das gerne so genannten
einmal preis und dann machen wir weiter
kämpft die zeigt darf nicht das ist ein
unveröffentlichtes produkt wir schreiben
mal als 50 dafür jetzt kommt türchen
nummer 11
blue berry blue berry bros
und warum ist er so lecker vor allem
sind das nun müsse amaranth und hat
kürzlich gestand ich glaube
also hey sponsor wie fleece
sehr gerne feste riegel of the gossip
also der regel kostet 190 ps die anderen
regeln hast mir
guttut nummer ab 12
ein kalter doña gutschein ja nicht wie
man eine gratis strumpfhose und 20
prozent rabatt also null euro by the way
der kalender wird danach nicht
weggeschmissen daraus kann man
das packen wir denn da aus kuchen
zusammen
[Gelächter]
türchen nummer 13
ja kann ich denn halten müssen das ruhig
wir sind auch drin war sinnlos man tee
und
kakao
was ist das
was richtig mache ich erstmal das liegt
schon sehr niedrig wie nicht mehr
akzeptiert
[Musik]
sehr parallel ich ja diese nach clusters
und 29 sabato einen persönlich würde das
sogar noch mehr kosten weil wir rechnen
immer vom kilo preis runter das ist
eigentlich schon sehr fair gerechnet am
sonntag konnten video sehr groß also
leute sonntag unbedingt ein schönes für
mich ein sehr großes als kommt sehr
kritische phase
gucken an chips ich glaube sie hat sehr
viele neue produkte herum probiert
alles probieren
ja gut zum backen also so einzelnen
schmeckt zeit trocken also weil
irgendwie jetzt den preis nicht kennen
haben wir gar kein bisschen nachgeguckt
deshalb gehen wir jetzt so auf
14 15 euro es ist ein
protein war muss ich schokoladen und
lecker wer hat dir zb 2,8 gramm zucker
der regel kostet zwei euro
29 ich weiß alles
[Musik]
schon mal gesehen ich habe das zwar ist
gut slacker drei bären triberg bridges
ja lecker das kostet 50 cent am 17
geschmeckt sagt ich probiere jetzt puren
kakaobutter also kakaobohnen stücke
umgerüstet jetzt kommt
[Musik]
nun
marco k
ja was hat das jetzt gekauft wir haben
die caps mit ähnlichen produkten
verglichen und schreiben 275 auf mein
konto ist für viele bauern
ja
sogar besser als originaler born ich
finde es richtig auch 169 über typische
nummer 19
kennen wir alle
die
kirche
in afrika zu je
22 jetzt sind wir ein türchen nummer 20
haben wieder ihre klasse erfolgs mit
einem neuen geschmack bieten szene mein
clusters kosten 1 euro 29 ich kriege
aber teilzunehmen ich mich schon wieder
erdnuss
freilich nicht dass sie hätten nur noch
erst nach ca
besonders zwischen
dem hahn 21
java flocken
46 cent die organic
cotton hatte
operativ sollte käme
also quasi wie ihre eigene nur besser
die griechen sehr gut die riechen wie
diese gruppe muss diese mit locken
nach irgendwas heute trafen
[Musik]
nummer 23
war der stopp
haben wir einfach nur gegessen hat
die kokosnuss chips mit sword carroll
geschmack des ortes karamell einfach
sarah battle direkt soccer
sollten
also solltet karamell 139 okay schon
wieder sind hält den verlose ich kommt
den verlor sich das ist wieder ein nuss
riegel ok mitspieler unten und nüssen
und
der herrscherin show glück naht 109 und
jetzt beste thema kräuter es ist
heiligabend mussten
vor weihnachten du darfst
[Gelächter]
einmal haben wir hier bio
basilikum wenn wir den kalender fertig
haben kann man das ja ein flammen zu
aber wir haben kein erde
dann haben wir hier noch einmal die
ganze nacht wenz kalender erklärt und
hier steht noch ich sende die herzliche
weihnachtsgrüße scanning qr code und
lass dich überraschen erwischt was zu
neugierig um auch den 40
never ever so und dann haben wir auch
noch das
grander ist in 24 drin was kostet das
genau
ja das ist ja das voll dass billige
töchter
sondern ist hier sind ein pappschale da
kann man dann seine basilikum seeds
reinmachen bisher wird und dann kann man
steckling als
stecklinge und dann kann man das
umtopfen das ist sehr praktisch ist auf
jeden fall behalten und für meinen
nächsten projekt benutzen jetzt brauchen
wir den ganzen preis und junge her ja
also jetzt um einen euro oder sondern zu
tippen nicht auch keinen rausgekommen
sind
44 wir sind bei 51 44 rausgekommen und
man muss ja nicht sachen hinterher
geschmissen bekommen aber mindestens den
einkaufspreis sollte man eigentlich
erreichen weil es sonst wie abzocke ist
also es könnte auch sein dass wir uns
vielleicht bei der einen oder anderen
sache so ein bisschen verrechnet haben
wo sie jetzt noch kein preis hatte aber
die anderen sachen vielleicht die wir so
nachgedacht haben vielleicht auch teure
sind aber hätte irgendwie erwartet dass
man für viel mehr was bekommt ja hätte
ich irgendwie auch aber so in ganz
allgemein ich finde den kalender gut ist
es ein guter kalender außer so gut
scheine es nicht sein also neben hat
auch mal riegel oder so das war aber
vielleicht wusste man diese gutscheine
reinbringen und nicht nur pamperin zu
haben so sehr nett gesagt
ich finde auch dass der kalender sehr
gut dass die produkte machen spaß
musiker aber ich bin schockiert dass
nicht mindestens bisschen mehr drin ist
als der einkaufspreis weil wir selbst
wenn wir uns bei zwei sachen verrechnet
haben es ist trotzdem nicht vielmehr
genau da kann man sich auch einfach
selber produkte über der themse kaufen
und dann klar dass solisten der mann
kamera live band ist wo ich mein richter
sind und sie möchte auf klassik achten
und so aber massa hat und diese ganzen
kleinen probe paket ja was sagen wir ich
finde so lecker aber freiwillig sondern
so
folgt auf jeden fall alle soraya auf
instagram und tic tac es ist zeit dass
du jetzt auch den fans sogar ihre
anfängt yes
damit irgendwann ein paar mails produkte
zugeschickt bekommen ist ich hoffe euch
hat das video gefallen das fragen wir
jetzt nicht künstler so und wir wären
länder videos